nos vies
sont la somme de nos choix
vont échapper au passé
Ethan cette mission
risque
le monde change
la vérité s'évapore la guerre est à
notre porte
ça fait longtemps cher ami
vous n'avez aucune idée de la puissance
que je représente
qui connaît votre histoire
qui en connaît la fin
écoutez moi le monde entier sera contre
vous
son destin est écrit devant nous écrire
le vôtre si leur arrive pas que ce soit
vous pourrez bien vous cacher n'importe
où je vous tuerai et ça c'est écrit
[Applaudissements]
quel est ton objectif
ultime
[Musique]
vies toujours plus à mes yeux que la
mienne
aucune de nos vies ne doit compter plus
que cette mission je ne suis pas
d'accord
[Musique]